[Applaudissements]
ces voix l'invité surprise
alors voilà évidemment vous vous êtes
dit invité surprise roi attend mais
c'est sûrement que ça va être énorme
peut-être que c'est un homme politique
connu un prix nobel de la paix barack
obama et non coucou c'est moi vanessa
caillou c'est qui
oui alors avec moi je suis là pour vous
détendre non je vais pas vous massez je
suis humoriste et je suis vraiment ravi
de participer à cet édifice après trois
heures de conférence 1 vous avez dû vous
concentrer à mort et que donc vous
attendez impatiemment affamés le buffet
alors en plus moi d'habitude en avant
mon spectacle il ya quelqu'un voilà une
première partie qui chauffe la salle qui
met l'ambiance bon là entre la forêt qui
meurt
et les lépreux au moyen-âge
là je trouve que mes collègues n'ont pas
vraiment et le japon
alors le thème de cette édition
chantilly c'est donc vivre ensemble
vivre ok le problème c'est ensemble
ouais parce que dans cet ensemble il ya
aussi ton oncle gérard et oui gérard un
kyste est celui qui jette ses papiers
par terre parce que ça crée de l'emploi
celui qui trouve que les féministes
casse un peu l'ambiance en soirée et qui
trouve qu'être gay bon être gay de toute
façon c'est la mode d'aujourd'hui donc
donc comment gérer gérard oui alors à
d'ailleurs à ce sujet vous savez qu en
france on a perdu quatre points de qi en
disant ouais ouais ouais c'est officiel
on devient de plus en plus cons ah oui
bon je sens en moi je le sens que je
deviens de plus en plus cons vraiment à
6 6 avant autant moi je vise et du zola
du claudel bon maintenant je lis des
postes facebook
mais avant je regardais des films
intéressants d'une heure trente
maintenant je regarde des vidéos de
chats effrayés par des concombres
maman et moi c'est qu'on me demande et
toi walesa tu préfères godard ou
truffaut
truffe gamm vert
mais très pratique l'humour un très
pratique on peut donc affiner notre
problématique comment vivre ensemble
alors qu'on devient de plus en plus
qu'on
atteint d'ailleurs j'ai un petit point
sémantique avant de continuer sur le
ensemble ensemble c'est les uns avec les
autres mais aussi en même temps et ça
c'est important si elle fait un ensemble
musical par exemple si les musiciens
jouent les uns avec les autres mais pas
en même temps 1 1 qui joue en décalé que
chacun vit sa vie bah ça donne le jazz
ah si le jazz c'est c'est le bordel le
jazz 1 à moi je ne saisis pas le concept
le jaf vraiment volé sa cinquième le
jazz non parce qu un super concert de
free jazz samedi tu veux venir 1
pourquoi je suis puni
non je suis allé à ce concert de free
jazz je n'ai pas compris non écoutez les
gars c'est que c'est quand ça commence
le concert parce que c'est long ça a
déjà commencé adacore non parce que moi
j'ai cru qu'il accordait encore leurs
instruments là ok
donc dans un premier temps à nouvel an
voir que vivre ensemble bof c'est pas
gagné
lorsque dès l'enfance on nous oblige
quand même à vivre avec des adultes
qu'on n'a pas choisi et ouais et qui en
plus sont là clairement pour nous
pourrir la vie 1 et oui à coups de range
ta chambre tu as la lumière c'est pas
versailles fille et bien si t'es pas
content tu a qualifié les voisins on
tout dire assez c'est mieux
moi avec mes parents j'ai de la chance
qu'ils sont très très très très chouette
si c'est très très classique en revanche
ce n'est pas un bruit très classique
très comme il faut un mon père a fait
carrière ma mère a fait des quiches
pendant les vacances d'ailleurs je suis
allé donc chez eux alors aller chez ses
parents en vacances pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas il ya comme des petites
règles à respecter 1 par exemple il ne
faut pas rester plus de commettre jours
on y va trois exactement si vous avez vu
c'est universel de l'histoire c'est ça
fait cinq ans que le premier jour c'est
moche et
deuxième joue vanessa troisième jour
fais comme ton père
alors une fois sur place moi je
conseille vraiment de respecter la règle
des 3 p alors patienter positiver et
pourquoi je suis venu
non bon bref donc vivre avec ses parents
d'accord mais trois jours max ouais
alors à vivre avec ses enfants c'est
différent
moi la cohabitation avec mon fils un ya
cinq ans il est super la cohabitation se
passe très bien parce qu'en fait je gère
plutôt bien enfin que mr ouai ouai c'est
cela mon petit secret pour gérer un
pouce et celles que ça intéresse ces
deux minutes et mon emploi du temps
18h31 vite au bain on a une minute de
retard quoi tu veux faire et pis mais
t'es malade
non parce que ton petit pipi là ça va
nous prendre deux minutes un deux
minutes du coup important forcément
baïeto retard pour le vin donc après en
retard pour leur part donc tu vas te
coucher trop tard donc deux matins tu
vas pouvoir te lever donc on va arriver
en retard à l'école alors moi tu vois je
me prenais une réflexion ta maîtresse à
ça va venir vite la journée d'accord 1
donc moi derrière je passe une journée
de merde le soir forcément on va te
fatiguer tous les deux donc ça va
gueuler ça va gueuler un non on va
passer une soirée de merde à eux deux
semaines de mer 20 mois de mer d'une
année de merville vie des
années 80 35 ans après dix ans de
psychothérapie tu vas me reprocher
d'abriter une mère autoritaire et 4 très
triste et c'est moi que devant faire 10
en thérapie pour me remettre à l'heure
et d'antan d'un
non mais moi ma copine de caro elle gère
super bien et que ces mômes je sais pas
comment elle fait bon déjà chez elle on
dirait un appartement témoin ces gamins
font de la hardt et du japonais
et elle fait ses yaourts elle même
parce que c'est mieux pour le transit
intestinal c'est sûr qu'au niveau
transiter le carreau c'est une
spécialiste un échiquier oui c'est ça
fait chier parce qu'en plus elle a une
vie de couple de malades attention mais
qui est tellement féministe que les gens
lui disent oh là là tu as de la chance
frank elle était de vachement ta femme à
la maison
c'est pas comme ça des messieurs
adresse que moi j'ai été en couple avec
le père de mon fils j'ai vécu avec lui
pendant dix ans d'ailleurs un 10 ans
c'est beau mais c'est long
si non il était très gentil dire
vraiment très très gentil très très
arrangeant un tu veux faire quoi mon
chéri ce week-end ah non c'est toujours
moi qui choisis en fait foi c'est toi
comme je veux eh ben je veux que toi tu
décides une balade en forêt ok alors
après on devient système en place un
week end je décide un week-end il décide
donc par exemple un week end venise un
week end balade en forêt un week end
reste au théâtre un week end balade en
forêt
un week end grosse fête à la maison un
week end
vous voyez c'est chiant quand même
non la vie alors en valeur après l'étape
de la séparation tally taf un peu
délicate de l'annonce à ton entourage à
ta mère tu quittes le père ton fils
enfin mes poules mais pour quoi faire
toi qui adore les balades en forêt
à l'arbre est un état de dépression
alors ça c'est vraiment l'étape où tout
est réussi quand il sort il pleut
quand tu manges tu es pattes c'est
directement dans sa casserole et le
téflon pas bon et quand quelqu'un tu
appelles c'est dominique leroy des
fenêtres tryba
est euh vous bien isolé oh oui
mais je suis bien fier ni soleil oui
parce que vivre ensemble bof mais vivre
seul bof bof aussi un donc moi je le
suis à la recherche d'une nouvelle
hommes de ma vie bon ça c'était mon plan
à ouais après je suis rapidement passer
au plan b un juste trouver un mec normal
bon visiblement l'univers avait d'autres
projets sur moi moi il m'a envoyé tous
ces boules et un ouais le pire c'est le
rabbin je trouve alors à temps le
problème c'est qu'avec la tendance
actuelle qui sait plus si le mec il est
radin ou écolo
c'est vrai il déjà vais partir en
week-end c'est une pince où il veut
réduire son empreinte carbone
c'est bah non écolo c'est beaucoup mieux
et non le vrai écolo alors souvent écolo
ça avec vegan ouais j'ai eu un ex vegan
comme ça il y avait des chaussures en
cuir de maïs oui c'est vrai j'ai
toujours eu envie de les mettre au micro
ondes pour moi
je n'ai pas fait
manger une théorie j'ai une théorie à
couper des hommes des femmes ça je pense
que les hommes nous tire vers le bas
alors je sais c'est un petit peu brutale
comme ça alors c'est comme ça mais bien
sûr je vais étayer mon propos étayés
c'est bon les mecs vous l'avez
attention c'est pas gai hier j'ai été à
la plage en rien à voir
non ça veut dire appuyé renforcer alors
et ayons
96,5 % des détenus sont des hommes eh
ouais 88% des serial killers sont les
hommes vous allez dire mais pourquoi
alors des gens le voient dès la
maternelle c'est vrai les petits gars
sont appelés petite fille crie est moi
de mon fils quand il s'embrouille avec
un copain au parc un élu en commune
direct non mon chéri on ne tape pas on
parle alors que la copine là la fille
pardon de ma copine caro elle est là et
ma maman d'élèves âgés de la dic a été
tu veux copine et moi j'ai dit est resté
pas gentil et l'a10 et va fait pas que
la gentille et me disent tu quittes
écuyers et elle a la vidéo en iran et
mais je divague et de magique de rigueur
que dans ma chérie tu parles trop la tap
alors deuxième raison c'est votre ego
messieurs oui si on prend par exemple le
lait le chiffre des serial killers il ya
beaucoup plus d'hommes tout simplement
partie ce parce qu'ils ne font plus ce
chopper way we la serial killeuse elle
elle est maligne elle tu dises crient
tous
asphyxie poison injection létale ça ne
se voit pas mais le sayyed couleurs les
aaa à bâle il te sens la tronçonneuse
comme ça
après ils te met le tout dans des sacs
poubelle à dire fluo tu vois un un champ
tendu jul et s'apaise ombaka paok prêt à
taper au un haka prirent part est un
gros pick up blanc rouge vise comme ça
que des flamands travers noël à l'est la
mère des répliques oh mais c'est fou ça
comment ils ont su
de la difficulté donc de vivre ensemble
c'est de gérer les hommes mais chili je
suis désolé messieurs mais les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes je vous adore moi
bien sûr évidemment je vous adore papa
tout c'est un enjeu non surtout un
lorsque j'ai rencontré quelqu'un ouais
ouais ouais il est il et il était temps
si vous n'êtes quand j'en étais arrivé
au stade du célibat où j'allais chez
l'ostéo juste pour que quelqu'un me
touche
si ben oui on l'a vu avec le confinement
en a besoin d'être touchés faveur d'un
besoin de contact doit les uns des
autres comme moi quand j'ai géré fait la
bise pour la première fois une copine
après les confinements mais non mais non
excusez moi car où ça va ça va bien mais
tu vois c'est que battue bat était
vivante quoi
vivre ensemble pour conclure je dirais
que vivre ensemble c'est un peu comme le
jazz 1 ces bordels c'est vrai on joue
tous une partition différente
souvent on comprend rien parfois
l'ensemble ne donne pas trop mal et
parfois il ya même des petits moments de
magie alors comment les capter ces
petits moments de magie je sais pas mais
bon on pourrait faire déjà de notre
mieux ça sera déjà pas mal merci
[Applaudissements]